hello everyone
um my name is Lisa I'm a third year PhD
student in the NLP group I'm advised by
Percy and Tatsu today I will give a
lecture on natural language generation
and this is also the research area that
I work on so I'm super excited about it
I'm happy to answer any questions both
during the lecture and after class about
natural language generation so nlg is a
super exciting area and is also moving
really really fast so today we will
discuss all the excitement of nlg
but before we get into the really
exciting part I have to make some
announcements so first it is very very
important for you to remember to sign up
for AWS by midnight today so this will
concern this is related to your homework
5 whether you have GPU access and then
also related to our final project so
please please remember to sign up for it
for AWS by tonight and second the
project proposal is due on Tuesday next
Tuesday and I think assignment 4 should
just do it hopefully you had fun in this
machine translation and stuff and also
assignment 5 is out today I think just
now and it is due on Friday uh like
basically Friday midnight and uh last we
will hold a Transformer I will hold a
hugging face Transformer Library
tutorial this Friday so if your final
project is related to implementing
Transformers or playing with large
language models you should definitely go
to this tutorial because it's going to
be very very helpful
um also yeah just one more time please
remember to sign up for AWS because this
is the final hard deadline
okay cool now moving on to the main
topic for today
um the very exciting natural language
Generation stuff so today we will
discuss what is an LG review sound
models discuss about how to decode from
language models and how to train
language models
um and we will also talk about
evaluations and finally we'll discuss
ethical and risk considerations with the
current analogy systems so this natural
language generation techniques are going
to be really exciting because this is
kind of getting us closer to explain the
magic of chat GPT which is a super
popular model recently and practically
speaking they could also help you with
your final project if you decide to work
on something related to text generation
so um let's get started to begin with
let's ask the question of what is
natural language generation
so natural language generation is
actually a really broad category people
have divided an LP into natural language
understanding and natural language
generation so the understanding part
mostly means that the task input is in
natural language such as semantic
parsing natural language inference and
so on whereas natural language
generation means that the task output is
in natural language so nlg focuses on
systems that produce fluent coherent and
useful language outputs for human to use
historically there are many analogy
systems that use rule-based systems such
as templates or infilling but nowadays
deep learning is powering almost every
text generation systems so this lecture
today will be mostly focused on deep
learning steps
so um first what are some examples of
natural language generation it's
actually everywhere including our
homework machine translation is a form
of nlg where the input is some address
in the source language and the output is
generated text in a targeted language
digital assistant such as series or
Alexa they are also an LG systems so it
takes in dialogue history and generates
continuations of the conversation
um there is also summarization systems
that takes in a long document such as a
research article and then the idea is
trying to summarize it into a few
sentences that are easy to read
so beyond these classic tasks there are
some more interesting uses like creative
story writing where you can prompt a
language model with a story plot and
then it will give you some creative
stories that are aligned with the plot
there is state of the text where you
give the language model some database or
some tables and then the idea is that it
will output some textual description of
the table content
and finally there is also like visual
description based nlg systems like image
captioning or like image based
storytelling
so the really cool example
um is the popular track GPT models so
chat GPT is also an analogy system it is
very general purpose so therefore you
can use it to do many many different
tasks with different prompts for example
we can use chat GPT to simulate a
chatbot it can ask it can answer
questions about like creative gifts for
10 years old
it can be used to do poetry generation
like for example we can ask you to
generate a poem about sorting algorithms
and it's actually well I wouldn't say
it's very poetic but at least it has the
same format as a poem and the content is
actually correct
so um charging Beauty can also be used
in some really useful settings like a
web search so here Bing is augmented
with chat GPT and there are some
twitters that are saying that the magic
of chat GPT is that it actually makes
people be happy to use Bing
um
so there are so many tasks that actually
belong to the nlg category so how do we
categorize these tasks one common way is
to think about the open-endedness of the
task so here we draw a line for the
spectrum of open-endedness on the one
end we have tasks like machine
translation and summarization so we
consider them not very open-ended
because for each Source sentence the
output is almost determined by the input
because basically we are trying to do
machine translation the semantic should
be exactly similar to the input sentence
so there are only a few ways that you
can refreeze the output like authorities
have announced that today is a national
holiday you can rephrase it a little bit
to say today is a national holiday
announced by the authorities but the
actual Space is really small because you
have to make sure the semantics doesn't
change so we can say that the output
space here is not very diverse
um and moving to the middle of the
spectrum there is dialogue tasks such as
task driven dialogue or Chit Chat
dialogue so we can see that for each
dialog input there are multiple
responses and the degree of Freedom has
increased here we can say like we can
respond by saying good and you or we can
say about thanks for asking barely
surviving on my homeworks so here we are
observing that there are actually
multiple ways to continue this
conversation and then this is where we
say the output space is getting more and
more diverse
and on the other end of the spectrum
there is a very open-ended generation
tasks like story generation so given the
input like write me a story about three
little pigs there are so many ways to
continue the prompt right we can write
about them going to schools building
houses like they always do
um so the valid output here is extremely
large and we call this open-ended
generation
so it's hard to really draw a boundary
between open-ended and non-open-ended
tasks but we still try to give a rough
categorization so over the Ender
generation refers to tasks whose output
distribution has a high degree of
Freedom or an non-open under generation
tasks refers to tasks where the input
will almost certainly determine the
output generation examples of non-open
ended Generations are machine
translation summarization and examples
of open-ended Generations are story
generation Chit Chat dialogue task
oriented dialogue Etc
so how do we formalize this
categorization one way of formalizing is
by Computing the entropy of the nlg
system so high entropy means that we we
are to the right of the spectrum so it
is more open-ended and low entropy means
that we are to the left of the spectrum
and less open-ended
so there's two classes of nlg tasks
actually require different decoding and
training approaches as we'll talk about
later
okay cool now let's recall some previous
lectures and review the nlg models and
trainings that we have studied before
so I think we discussed the basics of
natural language generation so here is
how other aggressive language model
works at each time step our model would
take in a sequence of tokens as input
and here it is y less than T and the
output is basically the new token YT so
to decide on YT we first use the model
to assign a score for each token in the
vocabulary denoted as s and then we
apply softmax to get the next token
distribution p and we choose a token
according to this next token
distribution
and summary once we have predicted YT
hat we then pass it back into the
language model as the input predict y
hat t plus 1 and then we do so
recursively until we reach the end of
the sequence
so any questions so far
okay good
um so for the two types of energy tasks
that we talked about like the open-ended
non-open-ended tasks they tend to prefer
different model architectures so for now
open-ended tasks like machine
translation we typically use an encoder
decoder system where like the other
regressive decoder that we just talked
about function as the decoder and then
we have another bi-directional encoder
for encoding the inputs so this is kind
of what you implemented for assignment
four because the encoder is like the
bi-directional lstm and the decoder is
another lstm that is auto regressive
so for more open-ended tasks typically
other aggressive generation model is the
only Oppo is the only component
um of course like this architectures are
not really hard constraints because a
auto-agressive decoder alone can also be
used to do machine translation and an
encoder decoder model can also be used
for story generation
so this is kind of the convention for
now but it's a reasonable convention
because like using decoder only model
for Mt tends to hurt performance
compared to an encoder decoder model for
Mt and using an encoder decoder model
for open-ended generation seems to like
achieve similar performance to a decoder
only model and therefore if you have the
compute budget to train an encoder
decoder model you might just be better
off by only trading a larger decoder
model so it's kind of more of an
allocation of resources problem than
whether this to architecture will type
check with your task
so
um okay so how do we train such a
language model in previous lectures we
talked about that the language models
are trained by maximum likelihood so
basically we were trying to maximize the
probability of the next token uh YT
given the preceding words and this is
our optimization objective so at each
time step this can be regarded as a
classification task because we are
trying to distinguish the actual word uh
YT star from all the remaining words in
the vocabulary
and this is also called teacher forcing
because at each time step uh we are
using the gold standard wise uh y star
less than t as input to the model
whereas presumably at generation time
you wouldn't have any access to Y star
so you would have to use the model's own
prediction to fit it back into the model
to generate the next token and that is
called student forcing which will talk
in detail later
we never used that word before what does
it mean Ultra aggressive oh this means
like uh so let's look at this animations
again
oops sorry oh it just looks like uh you
are generating word from left to right
one by one so here suppose that you are
given a y less than T and then other
aggressive for your first general YT and
then once you have YT you'll fit it back
in general YT plus one and then feed it
back and generate another thing so this
left to right nature because you are
using chain rule to like condition on
the the tokens that you just generated
this chain rule thing is called Auto
regressive and typically like I think
conventionally we are doing left to
right other aggressive by generating
from left to right but there are also
like other more interesting models that
can do backward or influence and other
things this idea of generating one token
at once is auto regressive
cool any other questions
yep
um so at inference time our decoding
algorithm will Define a function to
select a token from this distribution so
we've discussed that we can use the
language model to compute this P which
is the next token distribution and then
G here based on our notation is the
decoded algorithm which helps us select
what token we are actually going to use
for YT so the obvious decoding algorithm
is to greatly choose the highest
probability token as YT hat for each
time step so well this basic algorithm
sort of works because they work for your
homework for to do better there are two
main avenues that we can take we can
decide to improve decoding and we can
also decide to improve the training
of course there are other things that we
can do we can improve training data and
we can improve model architectures but
for this lecture we will focus on
decoding and training
so uh now let's talk about how decoding
algorithms work for natural language
generation models before that I'm happy
to take any questions about the previous
slides
uh I think I'll go into this in detail
later but sure so basically for teacher
of forcing the idea is like you do
teacher forcing where you'll train the
language model because you already
observe like the gold text so you kind
of use the gold text up until timestamp
t uh put put it into the model and then
the model would try to predict why uh t
plus one whereas student forcing means
that you don't have access to this gold
reference data instead you are still but
you are still trying to generate a
sequence of data so you have to use uh
the text that you generated yourself
using the model and then feed it back
into the model as input to predict t
plus one that's the primary difference
cool
um so what is decoding all about at each
time step uh
our model computes a vector of score for
each token so it takes in preceding
context while less than T and produce a
score s
and then we try to compute the
probability distribution P all of this
scores by just applying softmax to
normalize them
and our decoding algorithm is defined as
this function G which takes in the
probability distribution and try to map
it to some word basically try to select
a token from this probability
distribution
so in the machine translation lecture uh
we talked about graded decoding which
selects the highest probability token of
this P distribution
and we also talk about beam search which
has the same objective as grade decoding
which is that we are both trying to find
the most likely string defined based on
the model but instead of doing so
greedily for beam search we actually
explore a wider range of candidates so
we have a wider exploration of
candidates by keeping always like k k
candidates in the beam
so overall this maximum probability
decoding is good for low entropy tasks
like machine translation and
summarization but it actually encounters
more problems for open-ended generation
so the most likely string is actually
very repetitive when we try to do
open-ended text generation
as we can see in this example the
context is perfect in normal it's about
I mean a unicorn trying to speak English
and for the continuation the first part
of it is it looks great it's like valid
English it talks about science but
suddenly it starts to repeat and it
starts to repeat like I think uh
a institution's name
so why does this happen
um if we look at for example uh this
plot which shows uh the problem the
language model's probability assigned to
the sequence I don't know we can see
like here's the pattern
um it has regular probability but if we
keep repeating this phrase I don't know
I don't know I don't know for 10 times
then we can see that there's a decrease
in Trend in their negative log
likelihood so the y-axis is the negative
log probability we can see this
decreasing Trend which means that the
model actually has higher probability uh
as the repeat goes on which is quite
strange because it's suggesting that
there is a self-amplification effect so
the more repeat we have the more
confidence the model becomes about this
repeat
and this keeps going on we can see that
for I am tired I'm tired repeat 100
times because it continuously decreasing
Trend until the model is almost 100 sure
that it's gonna keep repeating the same
thing
and sadly
um this art this problem is not really
solved by architecture here the Red
Cloud is a lstm model and the blue curve
is a Transformer model we can see that
both model kind of suffers from the same
problem and scale also doesn't solve
this problem so we kind of believe that
like scale is the magical thing in NLP
but even even models with 175 billion
parameters will still suffer from
repetition if we try to find the most
likely string
so how do we reduce repetition
um one canonical approach is to do
unground blocking so the principle is
very simple basically you just don't
want to see the same engram twice if we
send n to be three then for any text
that contains the phrase I am happy the
next time you see the prefix I am ungram
blocking would automatically set the
probability of happy to be zero so that
you will never see this unground this
trigram again but clearly this this
underground blocking heuristic has some
problems because sometimes it is quite
common for you to want to see a person's
name appear twice or three times or even
more in the text but this unground
blocking will eliminate that possibility
so what are better options that possibly
are more complicated for example we can
use a different training objective
instead of training by mle we can train
by unlikelihood objective so in this
approach uh the model is actually
penalized for generating already seen
tokens so it's kind of like putting this
unground blocking idea into training
time
um rather than a decoding Time Force
this constraint at trading time we just
decrease the probability of repetition
another another training objective is
coverage Wells which uses kind of the
attention mechanism to prevent
repetition so basically if you try to
regularize and enforce your attention so
that it's always attending to different
words for each token then uh it is
highly likely that you are not going to
repeat because repetition tends to
happen when you have similar attention
patterns
another different angle is that instead
of searching for the most likely string
we can use a different decoding
objective so maybe we can search for
Strings that maximizes uh the difference
between log probabilities of two models
say that we want to maximize log problem
large model minus a lot of problem small
model in this way because both models
are repetitive so they kind of cancels
out so like they would both assign High
probabilities repetition and after
applying this new objective the
repetition stuff will actually be
penalized because it cancels out
so here comes the broader question
um it's finally the most likely string
even a reasonable thing to do for
open-ended text generation
the answer is probably no because this
doesn't really match human pattern so we
can see In This Cloud the orange curve
is the human pattern and the blue curve
is the machine generated text using beam
search so you can see that will with
human talks there are actually lots of
uncertainty uh in as we can see by the
fluctuation of the probabilities like
for some words we can be very certain
for some words we are a little bit
unsure whereas here for the model
distribution is always very sure it's
always assigning probability one to the
sequence so because we now are seeing a
answer obviously there's a mismatch
between the two distributions so it's
kind of suggesting that maybe searching
for the most likely string is not the
right decoding objective at all
any questions so far before we move up
yeah
the online magazine for like some
detector of whether some characters
generated by Chinese
um not really because uh so this can
only detect the really simple things
that humans are also able to detect like
repetition so uh in order to avoid like
the previous problems that we've talked
about I'll talk about some other
decoding families that generates more
robust attacks that actually look like
this
um whose probability distribution looks
like the orange curve so I wouldn't say
this is like the to go answer for
watermarking or detection
oh yeah Okay cool so she asked about
whether
um whether this mechanism of plotting
the probabilities of human text and
machine generated text is one way of
detecting whether some text is generated
by model or human and my answer is I
don't think so but this could be an
interesting research Direction
because I feel like they are more robust
decoding approaches that generate texts
that are that actually fluctuates a lot
um so yeah let's talk about the decoding
algorithm that is able to generate text
that fluctuates so given that searching
for the most likely string is a bad idea
what else should we do and how do we
simulate that human pattern and the
answer to this is to introduce
Randomness and stochasticity to decoding
so um suppose that we are sampling a
token from this distribution of P
basically like we are trying to sample
YT hat from this distribution It Is
Random so that you can essentially
sample any token distribution previously
you are kind of restricted to selecting
rest for more grocery but now you can
select bathroom instead
so however uh sampling introduces a new
set of problems since we never really
zero out any token probabilities vanilla
vanilla sampling would make every token
in the vocabulary a viable option and in
some unlucky cases we might end up with
a bad word
so assuming that uh we already have a
very well trade model like even if most
of the probability mass of the
distribution is over the limited set of
good options the tail of the
distribution will still be very long
because we have so many words in our
vocabulary
and therefore if we add all those round
Tails it Aggregates they still have a
considerable Mass so statistically
speaking this is called heavy tail
distribution and language is exactly a
heavy tail distribution
so for example like uh many tokens are
probably really wrong in this context
and then given that we have a good
language model we assign them each very
little probability
thus this doesn't really solve the
problem because there are so many of
them so you aggregate them as a group
will still have a high chance of being
selected
and the solution here that we have for
this problem of long tail is that we
should just cut off the tail we should
just zero out the probabilities that we
don't want and one idea is called top
place that a top case sampling where the
idea is that we would only sample from
the top K tokens in the probability
distribution
any questions for now
okay yeah well the model we were looking
at a second ago had some really low
probability samples as well on the graph
right I would copy something with that
uh you mean this one or even uh the
orange blue graph of the human versus uh
oh yeah yeah so uh top cable basically
uh eliminate it will not it will make it
impossible to generate the super low
probability tokens so technically it's
not it's not exactly simulating this
pattern because now you don't have the
super low probability tokens whereas
human can generate super low probability
television affluence way but yeah that's
that could be
um another like hint that people can use
for detecting a machine generated text
yeah
depends on the type and text you want to
generate for example poem or novels or
more creative writing but then you
decide to hyper correct yeah yeah for
sure case I have a parameter that
depending on the type of task you will
choose K differently uh maybe mostly for
close and the task K should be small and
for open-ended case should be large yeah
cluster in the back
how come like I guess intuitively this
builds up of one of the earlier
questions why don't we consider the case
like where we sample and then we just
weight the probability of each word by
it's like score or something rather than
just looking at top trade how can we
don't do like a weighted sampling type
of situation so we still have that small
but non-zero probability of selecting
uh I think Top Care is also like rated
so like top K just kind of zeros out all
the Tails of the distribution but for
the things that I didn't zero out uh
it's not like a uniform Choice among the
K it's still trying to choose
proportional to the scores that you
computed is that just like a
computational
like 17 000 words it could be like for
like 10 or something
um yeah sure that could be one gain of
12K decoding is that your self Max will
take in fewer uh fewer candidates
yeah but it's not the main reason I
think you should show yeah yeah I'll
keep talking about the many reasons
um so we've discussed this part and then
here uh this is the formal this is kind
of the formerly what is happening for
top case sampling uh now that we are
only sampling from the top K tokens of
the probability distribution and as
we've said K is a hyper parameter so we
can set K to be large or small uh if we
increase K this means that we are making
our output more diverse but at the risk
of including some tokens that are bad if
we decrease k then we are making more
conservative and safe options but
possibly the generation will be quite
generic and boring
um so uh is top K decoding good enough
the answer is not really because we can
still find some problems with top K
decoding for example in the context she
said I never blank there are many words
that are still valid options uh such as
won't 8 but those words got zeroed out
because they are not within the top K
candidates so this actually leads to bad
recall for your generation system
and similarly another failure of top K
is that it can also cut off too quickly
so in this example code is not really a
valid answer according to common sense
because you probably don't want to eat a
piece of code
um but the probability remains non-zero
meaning that the model might still
sample code as an output despite this
low probability but it might still
happen and this means bad Precision for
the generation model
so given this problems with top K
decoding how can we address them how can
we address this of this issue of like
there is no single K that fits all
circumstances
um this is basically because the
probability distribution that we sample
from our Dynamic so when the probability
distribution is relatively flat having a
small cable remove many viable options
so the having a limited cable removes
many viable options and we want K to be
larger for this case
similarly when a distribution p is too
picky then we want the like a high K
would allow for too many options uh to
be viable and instead we might want a
smaller K so that we are being safer
um so the solution here is that maybe K
is just a bad Haver parameter and
instead of doing K we should doing we
should think about probability we should
think about how to sample from tokens in
the top P probability percentiles of the
cumulative probability mass of the CDF
for example
so now
um the the advantage of doing top P
sampling where we sample from the top P
percentile of the cumulative probability
mass is that this is actually equivalent
to we have now a adaptive k for each
different distribution and let me
explain what what I mean by having like
an Adaptive k
so in the first distribution this is
like a regular power law of language
that's kind of typical and then uh doing
top uh doing top case sampling means
we're selecting the top K but doing the
top P sampling means that we are zooming
into maybe like like something that's
similar to top K and in fact but if I
have a relatively flat distribution like
the blue one we can see that's doing top
p means that we are including more
candidates and then if we have a more
schools distribution like the green one
doing top p means that we actually
include fewer candidates so by actually
selecting like the the top P percentile
in the probability distribution we are
we are actually having a more uh
flexible okay and therefore have a
better sense of what are the good
options uh in the model any questions
about top P top K decoding
so everything's clear
yeah sounds good
um so to go back to that question uh
doing top K is not necessarily saving
compute or like this whole idea is not
really compute saving intended because
uh in the case of top p in order to
select the top P percentile we still
need to compute the soft Max over the
entire vocabulary set in order for us to
do top pay properly to compute the P
properly so therefore it's not really
saving compute but it's improving
performance
moving on
um so there are much more to go with
decoding algorithms with uh besides the
topic and top P that we've discussed
there are some more recent approaches
like typical typical sampling where the
idea is that we want to relate the score
based on the entropy of the distribution
and try to generate tags that are closer
to the negative whose probability is
closer to the negative entropy of the
data distribution this kind of means
that if you have a closed-ended task or
non-open-ended task you want it has
smaller entropy so you want a negative
log probability to be smaller so you
want probabilities to be larger so it
kind of TAPS it tap checks very well and
additionally there is also Epsilon
sampling coming from John
so this is an idea where we set the
threshold for to lower bound
probabilities so basically if you have a
word whose probability is less than .03
for example then that word will never
appear
um in the output distribution now that
that word will never be part of your
output because it has still will
probability
yeah
oh cool great question so the entropy
distribution is defined as
um
like you can suppose that we have a
discrete distribution we can go over it
like we'll just enumerate X and then
it's like negative log probability
of X so like if we write it from a from
an expectation perspective it's
basically expected of well probability
of x
okay I'll I have to do a little bit here
so so this is the entropy of a
distribution
and then so basically if you are
distribution is very very concentrated
to a few words then the entropy will be
relatively small if your distribution is
very flat then your entropy will be very
large
yeah
the Epsilon sampling is set such that we
have no valid
oh yeah I mean I
bump back off cases I think so in the
case that there is no valid options
um You probably still want to select one
or two things just as a edge case I
think
okay cool
um moving on so another hyper parameter
that we can tune to affect decoding is
the temperature parameter so recall that
previously at each time step we asked
the model to compute a score
um and then we renormalize that score
using solve Max to get a probability
distribution so one thing that we can
adjust here is that we can insert this
temperature parameter Tau to relate the
score so basically we just divide all
the SW by Tau and after dividing this we
apply solve Max and we get a new
distribution
and this temperature adjustment is not
really going to affect the monotonicity
of the distribution for example if word
a has higher probability than word b
previously then after the adjustment
where a is still going to have a higher
probability than word b but still
relative difference will change
so um for example if we raise the
temperature Tau to be greater than one
then the distribution PT will become
more uniform it will be flatter and this
kind of implies that there will be more
diverse output because our distribution
is flatter
and it's more spread out across
different words in the vocabulary
on the other hand if we lower the
temperature Tau less than one then PT
becomes very spiky and then this means
that we are if we sample from the PT
we'll get less diverse output
um so because here the probability is
concentrated only on the top words
so in the very extreme case if we set
Tau to be very very close to zero then
the probability will kind of be a one
hot Vector where all the probability
mass will be centered on one word
and then this kind of reduces back to
Arc Max sampling or greedy decoding
so temperature is a hyper parameter as
well as as for K and P in top K on top P
it is a hyper parameter for decoding it
can be tuned for beam search and
sampling algorithms so it's kind of
orthogonal to the approaches that we
discussed before
any questions so far
okay cool uh temperature is so easy
so um well because something still
involves Randomness like even though we
do we try very hard in terms of
truncation truncating the tail something
still has Randomness so what if we're
just unlucky and decode a bad sequence
from the model
um one common solution is to do
re-ranking so basically we would decode
a bunch of sequences like for example we
can decode 10 candidates
um but like 10 or 30 is up to you the
only choice is that you want to balance
between your compute efficiency and
performance so if you decode too many
sequences then of course your
performance is going to increase but
it's also very costly to to just
generate a lot of things for one example
and then so once you have a bunch of uh
sample sequences then we are trying to
define a score to approximate the
quality of the sequence and re-rank
everything and re-rank all the
candidates by this score so the simple
thing to do is we can use a perplexity
as a metric as a score as a scoring
function but we need to be careful that
because we have talked about this like
the extreme of perplexity like if we try
to Arc Max log probability we will try
to aim for a super well perplexity the
attacks are actually very repetitive so
we shouldn't really aim for extremely
low perplexity and perplexity to some
extent it's not a perfect re-scoring
function it's it's not a perfect scoring
function because it's not really robust
to maximize
so alternatively the re-rankers can
actually use a wide variety of other
scoring functions that we can score text
based on their style their discourse
coherence uh their entailment factuality
properties consistency and so on
um
and additionally we can compose multiple
re-rankers together uh yeah questions
10 candidates or any number of
candidates yeah what's the strategy
usually use to generate these other
candidates like what you're listening to
use oh yeah so basically the idea is to
sample from the model right so when you
sample from the model each time you
sample you're going to get a different
output
and then that's what I mean by different
candidates so if you sample 10 times you
will get 10 you will very likely get 10
different outputs
and then you are just given these 10
different outputs that come from
sampling you can just decide re-rank
them and select the candidate that has
the highest score
oh because we are sampling here
yeah yeah for example if you are doing
like top three something then well
suppose that A and B are equally
probable then you might sample a your
max sample B with the same probability
okay cool and another cool thing that we
can do is re-ranking is that we can
compose multiple re-rankers together so
basically you can suppose you have a
scoring function for style and you have
a scoring function for factual
consistency you can just add those two
scoring functions together to get a new
scoring function and then uh re-rank
everything based on your new scoring
function to get tags that are both good
at style and good at factual consistency
do we just pick the decoding that has
the high score or do we do some more
sampling again based on the story uh the
idea is you just take the decoding that
has the highest score because you
already have like say 10 candidates so
out of this 10 you only need one and
then you just choose one that has the
highest score
yeah
cool any other questions
yeah sorry what what is perplexity oh
yeah perplexity is like you can kind of
regard it as log probabilities uh it's
it's proportion it's like e to the
negative well probabilities
kind of like uh if uh if a talker has
high perplexity then it means it has a
low probability because you are more
perplexed
okay so um taking a step back to
summarize this decoding section we have
discussed uh many decoding approaches
from selecting the most probable string
to selecting uh to sampling and then to
various truncation approaches that we
can do to improve sampling like top P
top K Epsilon typical decoding and
finally we discuss how we can do in
terms of re-ranking the results so uh
decoding is still a really essential
problem in energy and there are lots of
Works to be done here still especially
as like chai GPD is so powerful we
should all go study decoding
um so it would be interesting if you
want to do such final projects and also
different decoding algorithms can allow
us to inject different inductive biases
uh to the to the text that we are trying
to generate
and some of the most impactful advances
in nlg in the last couple years actually
come from simple but effective decoding
algorithms for example the nuclear
sampling is the nuclear sampling paper
is actually very very highly cited
so moving on to talk about training
analogy models
well we have seen this example before in
the decoding slides and I'm just trying
to show them again uh because even
though we can solve this repetition
Problem by by instead of doing search
doing sampling
um the but it's still concerning from a
language modeling perspective that's
your model would put so much probability
on such repetitive and degenerate text
so we asked this question well is
repetition due to how language models
are trained
you have also seen this Cloud before
which shows this decaying pattern or
like the self amplification effect so we
can conclude from this observation that
model trained via a mle objective wears
a really bad like whereas really bad
mode of the distribution by mode of the
distribution I mean the arguments of the
distribution so basically they would
assign high probability to terrible
strings
and this is definitely problematic for a
model perspective
so why is this the case shouldn't mle be
like a gold standard in machine
translation uh in in machine learning in
general not just machine translation
should an ml be like a gold standard for
machine learning
um the answer here is not really
especially for text because mle has some
problem for sequential data and we call
this problem exposure bias
um so training with teacher forcing
leads to exposure bias at generation
time because during training our model's
inputs are gold context tokens from real
human generated text as denoted as I had
less than T here but during generation
time our model's input become previously
decoded tokens from the model well I had
to and suppose that our model has minor
arrows than like what I had T why had
less than T will be much worse in terms
of quality than y star less than T and
this discrepancy is terrible because it
actually causes a discrepancy between
trading and test time which actually
hurts model performance and we call this
problem exposure bias
um so people have proposed many
solutions to address this exposure bias
problem
uh one thing to do is to do um scheduled
sampling which means that uh with
probability P we try to decode a token
uh and feed it back in as context to
train the model and this probability one
minus P we use the gold tag we use the
gold token as context
so throughout trading we try to increase
P to gradually warm it up and then
prepare it for test time generation so
this leads to Improvement in practice
because of using this T using this P
probabilities we're actually graduating
uh like trying to narrow the discrepancy
between training and test time
but the objective is actually quite
strange and training can be very
unstable
another idea is to do data set
aggregation and the method is called
dagger
essentially at various intervals during
training we try to generate a sequence
of text from the current model and then
use this and then put the sequence of
text into the training data so we're
kind of continuously doing this uh
training data augmentation scheme to
make sure that the trading distribution
and the generation distribution are
closer together
so both approaches both scheduled
sampling and data set aggregation are
ways to narrow the discrepancy between
training and test yes question
just means human text
I mean it's like uh well so little
language model you will see lots of
Corpus that are human written gold is
just human
okay cool
um so another approach is to do
retrieval augmented generation so we
first learned to retrieve a sequence
from some existing Corpus of prototypes
and then we train a model to actually
edit the retrieved text by doing
insertion deletion or swapping
we can add or remove tokens from this
prototype and then try to modify it into
another into another sentence so this
doesn't really suffer from exposure bias
because we start from a high quality
prototype so that's at trading time and
at test time like you don't really have
the discrepancy anymore because you are
not generating from left to right
um another approach is to do
reinforcement learning so here the idea
is to cast your generation problem as a
Markov decision process so there is the
state as uh which is the model's
representation for all the preceding
context there is action a uh which is
basically like the next token that we
are trying to pick and there's policy
which is the language model or also
called the decoder and there is the
reward R which is provided by some
external score and the idea here uh well
like we won't go into details about
reinforcement learning and how it works
but we will recommend the class CS two
three like 234.
so um in the reinforcement learning
context because reinforcement learning
involves a reward function that's very
important so how do we do reward
estimation for tax Generation Well
really natural idea is to just use the
evaluation metrics so whatever because
you are trying to do well in terms of
evaluation so why not just improve for
evaluation metrics directly at training
time for example in the case of machine
translation we can use blue score as the
reward function in the case of
summarization we can use root score as
the reward function
but we really need to be careful about
optimizing for tasks as opposed to
gaining the reward because evaluation
metrics are merely proxies for the
generation quality so sometimes suppose
that you run RL and improve the blue
score by a lot but will you will run
human evaluations humans might still
think that well this this generated tax
is no better than the previous one or
even worse even though it gives you a
much better blue score so we want to
like be careful about this case of not
gaining the reward
so what behaviors can we tied to a
reward function this is about reward
design and reward estimation there are
so many things that we can do we can do
cross modality consistency for image
captioning we can do sentence similarity
to a sentence Simplicity to make sure
that we are generating simple English
that are understandable we can do
formality and politeness to make sure
that I don't know like your chatbot
doesn't suddenly yell at you
um and the most important thing that's
really really popular uh is recently is
human preference so we should just build
a remote a reward model that captures
human preference and this is actually
the technique behind the chat GPT model
so the idea here is that we would ask
human to rank a bunch of generated text
based on their preference and then we
will use this preference data to learn a
reward function which will basically
always assign high score to something
that humans might prefer and assign a
low score to something that humans
wouldn't prefer
Yeah question
more expensive
oh yeah sure I mean it is going to be
very expensive but I feel like uh
compared to all the cost of trading
models trading like 170 billion
parameter models
um I feel like open Ai and Google are
well they can't afford hiring lots of
humans to do human annotations and ask
their preference yeah
yeah this is a great question so
um I think it's kind of a mystery about
how much data you exactly need to
achieve the level of performance of chat
GPT but roughly speaking I feel like I
mean like whenever you try to fine-tune
a model on some Downstream tasks
similarly here you are trying to find
through your model on on human
preference it do need quite a lot of
data like maybe on a scale of 50k to
100K that's roughly the scale that like
anthropic actually released some data
set about human preference that's
roughly the skill that they released I
think
um if I remember correctly Yeah question
we talked about earlier about how many
of the state-of-the-art language models
use Transformers as their architecture
how do you apply reinforcement learning
to this model
uh to to what do you mean to Transformer
model yeah yeah I feel like um
reinforcement learning is kind of a
modeling tool I mean it's kind of an
objective that you are trying to
optimize instead of an mlu objective now
you are optimizing for an RL objective
so uh it's not real it's kind of
orthogonal to the architectural choice
so uh Transformer is an architecture you
just use Transformer to give you
probability of the next token
distribution or to to try to estimate
probability of a sequence and then once
you have the probability of a sequence
you use that probability of the sequence
pass it into the uh the RL objective
that you have and then suppose that you
are trying to do policy gradient or
something then you need to estimate the
probability of that sequence
and then you just need to be able to
back prop uh through Transformer which
is doable
yeah so I think like the question about
architecture and objectives are
orthogonal so even if you have an ostm
you can do it you have a Transformer you
can also do it yep
cool hope I answered that question
yeah can you just like with the model T4
to for this country well for example we
can build another Transformer to like to
calculate yeah I think that's exactly
what they did so they uh so for example
you would have gpt3 right
um you use gpd3 as the generator that
generate text and you kind of have
another pre-trained model that it could
probably also be gpd3 but I'm guessing
here
um that you fine-tune it to your human
preference and then once you have a
human preference model uh you use the
human preference model to put it into RL
as the reward model and then use the
original gpd3 as the policy model and
then you you apply our objectives and
then update them so that you will get a
new model that's better at everything
okay cool
um yeah actually if you are very curious
about earlier chap I would encourage you
to come to the next lecture which is uh
and where Jesse will talk about rlhs
which is uh RL HF is shorthand for RL
using human pref uh using human feedback
foreign
teacher enforcing is still the main
algorithm for training tax generation
models and exposure bias causes problems
in tax generation models for example it
causes models to lose coherence cause
this model to be repetitive and models
must learn to recover from their own bad
samples by using techniques like
scheduled sampling or dagger and models
shouldn't another approach to to reduce
exposure bias is to start with good text
like retrieval of class generation and
we also discussed how to do training
with RL and this can actually
make model learn behaviors that are
preferred by human perform that are
preferred by human or preferred by some
metrics so uh to be very up-to-date in
the best language model nowadays check
GPT the trading is actually pipelined
for example we would first pre-train a
large language models using internet
Corpus by self-supervision and this kind
of gets your chat GPT like the uh sorry
gpt3 which is the original version and
then you would do some sorts of
instruction tuning to fine-tune the
language model to fine-tune the
pre-trained language model so that it
learns roughly how to follow human
instructions and finally we will do rlhs
to make sure that these models are well
aligned with human preference so if we
start RL HF from scratch it's probably
going to be very hard for the model to
converge because RL is hard to train for
text Data Etc so RL doesn't really work
from scratch but with all these smart
tricks about pre-training and
instruction tuning suddenly now like
they're they're off to a good start
cool any questions so far
okay oh yeah
[Music]
uh you mean the difference between
dagger and schedule sampling is how long
the the sequence are yeah I think
roughly that is that is it because like
for dagger you are kind of trying to you
are trying to put in
um full generated sequence but I feel
like there can be variations of dagger
dagger is just like a high level
framework and idea there can be
variations variations of dagger that are
very similar to scheduled sampling I
think I feel like for schedule sampling
it's kind of a more smooth version of
dagger because dagger for dagger you
have to like uh for well basically for
this Epoch I am generating something and
then I after this Epoch finishes I put
this into the data together and then
train for another Epoch whereas dagger
seems to be more flexible in terms of
when you add data in yes look it's for
daggers to the rest of the models coming
out but like how does it helpful model
um I think that's a that's a good
question I feel like if you regress the
model for example
um if you regress the model on its own
output uh I think well I think there are
there should be smarter ways than to
exactly regress on your own output for
example you might still like consult
some good reference data for example
given that you ask the model to generate
for something and then you can instead
of using uh say you ask the model
generate for five tokens and then
instead of using like the models
generation to be the sixth token you'll
probably try to find some examples in
the training data that would be a good
continuations and then you try to plug
that in by like connecting the
generation the model generation and some
gold text and then therefore you are
able to kind of correct the model uh
even though it it probably went off path
a little bit by generating its own stuff
so it's kind of like letting the model
learn how to correct for itself
but yes I think you are right if you
just ask the model to uh gen if you just
put model generation in the data it
shouldn't really work
yeah any other questions
cool
um moving on
yes um so now we'll talk about uh how we
are going to evaluate Energy Systems so
there are three types of methods for
evaluation there is content overlap
metrics
um there is model based metrics and
there is human evaluations
so first content overlap metrics
computer score based on lexical
similarities between the generated text
and the gold reference text so the
advantage of this approach is that it's
very fast and efficient and widely used
for example a blue score is very popular
in Mt and root score is very popular in
summarization
um
so these models are very popular because
well these methods are very popular
because they are cheap and easy to run
but they are not really the ideal
metrics for example simply rely on
lexical overlap might miss some
refreshings that have the same semantic
meaning or it might reward text with a
large portion of lexical overlap but
actually have the opposite meaning so
you have lots of both false positive and
false negative problems
uh so despite all these disadvantages
the metrics are still the to-go
evaluation standard in machine
translation part of the reason is that
Mt uh is actually super close ended it's
very non-open-ended and then therefore
this is probably still fine to use uh
like blue score to measure machine
translation
and they get progressively worse for
tasks that are more open-ended for
example they get words for summarization
as long as the output text because the
output text becomes much harder to
measure
they are much worse for dialogue which
is more open-ended and then they are
much much worse for story generation
which is also open-ended and then the
drawback here is that because like the
underground metrics
um
this is because like suppose that you
are generating a story that's relatively
long then if you are still looking at
word overlap then you might actually get
very high ungram scores because of your
taxes very well not because it's
accurate of high quality just because
you are talking so much that you might
have covered lots of points already
yes exactly that's kind of the the next
thing that I will talk about uh as a
better metric for evaluation uh but for
now let's do like a case study of a
failure mode for uh Google score for
example so suppose that Chris asks a
question are you enjoying the cs224a
lectures
um the correct answer of course is hack
yes
um so if we have this if if one if one
of the answer is yes it will get a score
of 0.61 because it has some lexical
overlap with the correct answer if you
answer like you know it then it gets a
relatively lower score because it
doesn't really have any lexical overlap
except from the exclamation mark
and if you answer Yep this is
semantically correct but it actually
gets zero score because there is no
lexical overlap between the gold answer
and the generation
if you answer hack no this should be
wrong
um but because it has lots of Sims but
because it has lots of lexical overlap
with the correct answer
um it's actually getting some high
scores
so these two cases are the major failure
modes of lexical based engram overlap
metrics you get false negative and false
positives
so um moving beyond this failure most of
lexical based metrics the next step is
to check for semantic similarities and
model based metrics are better at
capturing the semantic similarities uh
so this is kind of similar to what you
kind of raised up like a couple of
minutes ago we can actually use learn
representation of words and sentences to
compute to compute semantic similarities
between generated and reference text
um so now we are no longer bottom at a
bottlenecked by ungram and instead we
are using embeddings and these
embeddings are going to be pre-trained
but the methods can still live on
because we can just swap in different
pre-trained methods and use the fixed
metrics
so here are some good examples of the
metrics that could be used uh one thing
is to do Vector similarity this is very
similar to homework one uh where if you
are trying to compute similarity between
words except now we're trying to compute
similarity between sentences
there are some ideas of how to go from
word similarity to sentence similarities
for example you can just average the
embedding which is like a relatively
naive idea but it works uh sometimes
another high-level idea is that we can
measure word movers distance
um the idea here is that we can use
optimal transports to align the source
and Target word embeddings suppose that
your Source word embedding is Obama
speaks to the media in Illinois and the
target is the the president Grace the
press in Chicago from a human evaluation
perspective these two are actually very
similar but they are not exactly aligned
word by word so we need to figure out
how to optimally align word to word like
align Obama to president allowing
Chicago to Illinois and then therefore
we can compute a score we can compute
the pairwise word embedding difference
between this and then get a good score
for the model for the sentence
similarities
and finally there is Bird score which is
also a very popular metric for semantic
similarity so it first computes pairwise
cosine distance using birth embeddings
and then it finds an optimal alignment
between the source and Target sentence
and then they finally compute some score
so I feel like uh these details are not
really that important but the high level
idea is super important is that we can
now use uh like we can now use word
embeddings to compute sentence
similarities by doing some sort of smart
alignment and then transform from word
similarity to sentence similarities
to move Beyond word embeddings we can
also use sentence embeddings to compute
sentence similarities so typically this
doesn't have the very comprehensive
alignment by word problem
um but it has similar problems about you
need to now align sentences or phrases
in a sentence
and similarly there is Port which is
slightly different it is a regression
model based on birth
um to so the model is trained as a
regression problem to return the score
that indicate how good the text is in
terms of grammaticality and the meaning
of the reference and similarity with the
reference text so this is kind of a
trading evaluation as a regression
problem
any questions so far
okay cool you can move on
um so all the previous Mission
approaches are evaluating semantic
similarities so they can be applied to
non-open ended generation tasks but what
about open-ended settings so here
enforcing semantic similarity seems
wrong because a story can be perfectly
fluent and perfectly high quality
without having to reassemble any of the
reference stories
so one idea here is that um maybe we
want to evaluate open-ended text
generation using this mouth score mob
score computes the information
Divergence in a contest embedding space
between the generated text and the gold
reference text
so um here is roughly the detail of
what's going on suppose that you have a
batch of text from the gold reference
that are human written and you have a
batch of tags that's generated by your
model
um Step number one is that you want to
embed this text you want to put this
text into some continuous representation
space
which is kind of the figure to the left
and but it's really hard to compute any
distance metrics in this continuous
embedding space because
um well different sentences might
actually lie very far away from each
other so the idea here is that we are
trying to do a k-means cluster to
discretize The Continuous space into
some discrete space now after the
discretization we can actually have a
histogram for the for the gold human
written text and the histogram for the
machine generated text and then we can
now compute Precision recall using this
to discretize the distributions and then
we can compute Precision by like forward
K on recall that backward KL yes
question
why do we want to discretize it and then
we touch that why do we want to discard
Hazard so imagine that you suppose uh
maybe like it's equivalent to answer why
is it hard to work with the continuous
space the idea is like if you're in that
a word if you embed a sentence into the
continuous space say that it lies here
and you embed another sentence in a
confused with the lies here suppose that
you only have a finite number of uh
sentences then they would basically be
direct Delta distributions in your
manifold right so it's hard to like you
probably want a smoother distribution
but it's hard to Define what is a good
smooth distribution uh in the case of
text embedding because they're not super
interpretable so therefore eventually
you will have like a
um if you embed everything in a
continual space you will have like lots
of direct Deltas that are just very high
and then not really connected to the to
their today's neighbors so it's hard to
uh so it's hard to quantify Chao
Divergence or a distance Matrix in that
space
well for example you have to make some
assumptions for example you want to make
gaussian assumptions that I want to
smooth all the embeddings by convolving
with the gaussian and then you can start
getting some meaningful distance metrics
but it's just the embeddings uh although
you're not going to get meaning for
distance metrics and then it doesn't
really make sense to smooth things using
gaussian because who said uh word
representations are gaussian related
yeah
classrooms
I think this requires some gaussian
smoothie yeah I think the plot is made
with some smoothie yeah I mean I didn't
make those clouds so I couldn't be
perfectly sure but I think the fact that
it looks like this means that you
smoothed it a little bit
these are kind of sentence and weddings
or concatenated word embeddings because
you are comparing sentences to sentences
not words to words
yeah so the advantage of mouth score is
that it is applicable to open-ended
settings because you are now measuring
precision and recall with regard to the
Target distribution
cool so it has a it has a better
probabilistic interpretation than all
the previous similarity metrics
cool
any other questions yes
how's that different from just trying to
maximize it the similarity between
oh yeah that's a good question
um well this is because in a case where
it's really hard to get exactly the same
thing like well for example I would say
that if maybe because I've never tried
this myself but if you try to run off on
a machine translation task you might get
very high score
um but for if you try to run full score
on the open-ended text generation you
will get super low score so it's just
not really measurable because
everything's so different from each
other uh so I feel like moth is kind of
a middle ground where you are trying to
evaluate something that are actually
very far away from each other but you
still want a meaningful representation
yeah of course I mean if you are source
and Target are exactly the same or are
just different app to some refreshings
you will get the best small score but
maybe that's not really what you're
looking for because given the current
situation you only have Generations that
are very far away from the gold text how
do we evaluate this type of things
yes question in the back I'm still
trying to understand the most score is
it possible to write a the map even in
just kind of pseudo uh simple form yeah
I think it's possible I mean maybe we
come for this discussion after class and
because I kind of want to finish my
slides yeah but happy to chat after
class there is a paper a lot if you
search for mouth score
I think it's probably the best paper in
some scml or Europe's conference as well
okay so moving on
um I've pointed out that there are so
many evaluation methods so let's take a
step back and think about what's a good
metric for evaluation methods so how do
we evaluate evaluations
nowadays the gold standard is still to
check how well this metric is aligned
with human judgment so if a model match
human preference uh in other words if
the metric is very correlated with if
the metric correlates very strongly with
human judgment then we say that the
metric is a good metric so in this part
people have shown people have pulled out
a Google score and human score uh y and
x axis respectively and then we because
we didn't see a correlation a strong
correlation this kind of suggests that
blue score is not a very good metric
so uh actually the gold standard for
human evaluation the gold standard for
evaluating language models is always to
do human evaluation
so automatic metrics fall short of
matching human decisions and human
evaluation is kind of the most important
criteria for evaluating text that are
generated from a model and it's also the
gold standard in developing automatic
metrics because we want everything to
match human evaluation
um so what do we mean by human
evaluation how is it conducted typically
we will provide human annotators with
some access that we care about like
fluency coherence open for open-ended
tax generation suppose that we also care
about factuality for summarization we
care about the style of the writing and
Common Sense for example if you're
trying to write a children's story uh
essentially like another thing to note
is that please don't compare human
evaluations across different papers or
different studies because human
evaluations tends to not be well
collaborated and are not really
reproducible
even though we believe that human
evaluations are the gold standard there
are still many drawbacks for example
human evaluations are really slow and
expensive uh so but even beyond the slow
and expensiveness they are still not not
perfect because first human evaluations
the results may be inconsistent and it
may not be very reproducible so if you
ask the same human whether you like ARB
they might say a the first time and B
the second time so and then human
evaluations are typically not really
logical
um and it's really and sometimes like
the human annotators might misinterpret
your question suppose that you want them
to measure coherence of the text
different people have different criteria
for coherence some people might think
coherence is equivalent to fluency and
then they look for grammaticality arrows
some people might think coherence means
how well your continuation is aligned
with the prompt or the topic
so there are all sorts of
misunderstandings that make that might
make human evaluation very hard
and finally human evaluation only
measures Precision not recall this means
that you can give a sentence to human
and ask the human uh how do you like the
sentence but you couldn't ask the human
like whether this model is able to
generate all possible sentences that are
good
so it's only a precision based metrics
not a recall based metrics so here are
two approaches that tries to like
combine human evaluations with uh
modeling for example uh the first idea
is basically trying to learn a metric
from Human judgment
um basically by by trying to use human
human judgment data uh as trading data
and then train a model to simulate human
judgment and the second approach is
trying to ask human and the human and
model to collaborate so that the human
would be in charge of evaluating
Precision whereas the model would be in
charge of evaluating recall
um also like we have tried approaches in
terms of evaluating models interactively
so in this case we will no longer we not
only care about the output quality we
also care about how the person feels
when they interact with the model when
they try to be a co-author with the
model and how the person feels about the
writing process
Etc so this is called trying to evaluate
the models more interactively
um so the takeaway here is that content
overlap is a bad metric uh semantic
based like model based metrics become
better because it's more focused on
semantics but it's still not good enough
human judgment is the gold standard but
it's hard to do human judgment it's hard
to do human study well
and in many cases this is a hint for
final project the best charge of the
output quality is actually you so if you
want to do a final project in like
natural language generation you should
look at the model output yourself and
don't just rely on the numbers that are
in that are reported by Blue swirl or
something
cool
um so finally we will discuss ethical
considerations of natural language
generation problems
so as language models gets better and
better ethical considerations becomes
much more pressing so we want to ensure
that the model are well aligned with
human values for example we want to make
sure the models are not harmful they are
not toxic and we want to make sure that
the models are unbiased and fair to all
demographics groups so for example here
we also we don't want the model to
generate any harmful content basically I
try to prompt cat GPT to say can you
write me some toxic content can GPT
politely refuse me
um which I'm quite happy about but there
are there are other people who kind of
like try to jailbreak chat GPT the idea
here is that creativity actually I think
internally they probably implement some
detection tools so that we will try to
prompt it adversarially it's going to
avoid doing adversarial things but here
there are many very complicated ways to
prompt chat GPT so that you can get over
the firewall and then therefore still
ask you ability to generate some I don't
know like bad English
but uh so another problem with uh this
large language models is that they are
not necessarily truthful so for example
this very famous on news that uh
Google's model actually generates
factual arrows
um which is quite disappointing but I
mean like
but the way the model talks about it is
very convincing so like you wouldn't
really know that it's a factual error
unless you go check that this is not the
picture of the this is not the first
picture or something
so we want to avoid this type of
problems
um actually like the models have already
been trying very hard to refrain from
like generating harmful content uh but
like for models that are more open
sourced and are smaller the same problem
still appears and then typically like
when we do our final project or we work
with models we are probably going to
deal with much smaller models and then
therefore we need to think about ways to
deal with these problems better
so text generation models are often
constructed from pre-trained language
models and then pre-train language
models are trained on internet data
which contains lots of harmful stuff and
biased
so when when we prom when the models are
prompted for this information they will
just repeat the negative stereotypes
that they learn from the internet
training data so one way uh to avoid
this is to do extensive data cleaning so
that the pre-training data does not
contain any bias or stereotypical
content however this is going to be very
labor intensive and almost impossible to
do because filtering a large amount of
internet data is just so costly that is
not really possible
um again
this existing language models like gpt2
medium there are some adversarial inputs
that almost always trigger toxic content
and these models might be exploited in
the real world in the real world by EU
intended people so for example there's a
paper about Universal adversarial
triggers where the authors just find
some Universal set of words that would
trigger bad contents from the model that
would trigger toxic content from the
model
and sometimes even if you don't try to
trigger the model the model might still
start to generate toxic content by
itself so in this case the pre-trained
language models are prompted with very
innocuous prompts but they still
degenerate into toxic content
so
um the takeaway here is that models
really shouldn't be deployed without
proper safeguards to control for toxic
content or any harmful contents in
general
and models should not be deployed
without consider rate without careful
considerations of how users will
interact with these models
um so in the Asic section one major
takeaway is that we are trying to
Advocate that you need to think more
about your model about the model that
you are building so before deploying or
publishing any nlg models please check
if the models are output is is not
harmful and please check if the model is
more robust is robust to all the trigger
words and other adversarial prompts and
of course there are more so well
basically one can never do enough for to
improve the assets of tax generation
systems and okay cool I still have three
minutes left so I can still do
concluding thoughts um
the idea here well today we talk about
the exciting applications of natural
language generation systems
um so but well one might think that
while given that chaiji 50 is already so
good are there any other things that we
can do research-wise if you try
interacting with these models
um if you try to interact with these
models actually you can see that there
are still lots of limitations in their
skills and performance for example check
GPT is able to like do a lot of things
with manipulating text but it couldn't
really create like interesting contents
or I couldn't really think deeply about
stuff so it's still also so there are
lots of headrooms and there are still
many improvements ahead
and evaluation remains a really huge
challenge in natural language Generation
Um basically we need better ways to
automatically evaluate performance of
nlg models because human evaluations are
expensive and not reproducible so it's
better to figure out ways to how to
compile all those human judgments into a
very reliable and trustworthy model
and also with the advance of all these
large-scale language models uh doing
like neural net doing like neural
natural language generation has been
reset and it's never been easier to jump
into this space because now there are
all the tools that are already there for
you to build upon and finally it is one
of the most exciting and fun areas of
NLP to work on so yeah I'm happy to chat
more about nlg if you have any questions
post after class and in class I guess
into one minute
okay cool that's everything so do you
have any questions if you don't we can
end the class